un sac un sac à main sac à main plus
cher que 200000
pourquoi tu gueules toujours
300000 mais non 160000 euros
regardez on en parle après ça a
énormément choqué les interdits de
160000 € pour un sac c'est un molette
Kelly
c'est magnifique
Coste ah vous avez des contacts
c'est mon ami mon frérot que j'embrasse
fort et qui me regarde tous les soirs il
est incroyable et bien donc c'est un
Kelly de chez Hermès Kelly sellier 25
Himalaya ça veut dire que le sac est
indirectement déjà il prend l'avion donc
c'est Italie le sac est tout seul et
tout il arrive voilà il se gère seul
quoi regarde
le sac le plus cher du monde est signé
Hermès il s'agit du sac Kelly 25
Himalaya qui a été mise aux enchères le
3 novembre dernier et qui est estimé
entre 120 000 et 160000 euros ça fait
beaucoup là non fabriqué en seulement
quelques exemplaires à l'année et il est
devenu le sac le plus cher du monde en
2020 à l'issue dans chair à Hong Kong il
est considéré comme un investissement
dans ces matériaux sont précieux en
disant la valeur du sac a déjà connu
Noos immense de 250%. en effet en 2020
leur fameux modèle Himalaya a trouvé un
acheteur pour 437 330 dollars de quoi
faire des jaloux
pas la peine de prendre les pancartes
tout ça ça va
je trouve que c'est génial au contraire
c'est la fierté c'est l'honneur de la
France
qui fabrique ça à la main en France et
le savoir-faire français évidemment que
c'est un prix démentiel évidemment que
moi je pourrai jamais me le payer allez
on va dire que c'est autre chose
interne le ça mais en fait c'est de la
merde
donc c'est juste extraordinaire et moi
je suis très fier que la maison Hermès
nous fasse briller dans le monde entier
en fait
moi je me dis ça au niveau de la santé
parce que là on vois plus les gars
[Applaudissements]
on dirait que tu es chauve du visage
[Rires]
non mais
c'est vrai c'est un truc de foues avec
la tondeuse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
rayonnante voilà et alors toute la vie
devant elle Oui au niveau de l'âge du
sac au niveau du sac c'est comme niveau
maintenant c'est vu comme un
investissement
Nabilla enfin quelques années non il y a
plein ou deux Nabilla qui avait fait le
buzz avec ce modèle là précis
du prix de ce sac et bah maintenant on
peut le revendre à ce prix là c'est
pareil avec les montres c'est pareil
avec les baskets exactement oui il y a
plein de gens qui se disent que ce sac
là ne vaut pas 160000 euros mais quand
on paye ça on paye la marque on paye les
gens qui font du tout les magasins les
bureaux et la rareté c'est devenu un
investissement et d'ailleurs quand vous
rentrez dans un magasin Hermès à part si
vous avez quelqu'un de charismatique
comme Cyril on ne vous vend pas de sac
mais c'est vrai on vous refuse des sacs
j'avais donné des consignes
non l'été dernier j'en ai cherché un je
me suis dit je vais peut-être faire un
investissement pour l'immobilier
au départ tu vas dans un magasin et en
fait il te disent non non même si l'on
ne vole pas
ce modèle-ci voilà
[Rires]
si vous avez vu la mise aux enchères
c'est 160000 euros
mais il est parti en 2020 à 360000 euros
donc là il partira peut-être il risque
d'être chiant et devant si vous voulez
pas un
et pour moi l'armée c'est la plus belle
marque française alors qu'est-ce que tu
dis façon génie je m'incline
alors parce que là en fait on n'a pas
compris ta phrase non mais je veux dire
non mais c'est génial c'est absolument
génial si la vérité qu'est-ce que tu en
penses je suis pas
fans alors je suis pas fan parce que
c'est l'histoire moi de du crocodile
comme c'est fabriqué en crocodile
c'est ça comme c'est fabriqué en
crocodile du Bénin c'est une espèce en
voie de disparition
en agglomération absolument j'étais sur
le périph ce weekend c'est vrai que on
n'est pas vus j'en ai vu j'en ai croisé
un comme ça qui était en limitation
d'ailleurs il était à 90 à l'Heure
Tranquille et c'est tout et c'est tout à
fait autorisé c'est légal qui donne même
un passeport pour qu'on voyage avec mais
oui parce que
c'est celui qu'on a là parfaite
pas du tout
très peu de chacun
autre chose à faire avec 160000 balles
quand même oh là là avec 160000 balles
déjà tu dois être refaire
même si j'ai l'argent je ne pourrai pas
si un jour je mets 160000 € dans un sac
j'espère que tu mets un point américain
et que tu me casses le ferai t'inquiète
pas
que le jour où je fais un truc comme ça
que tu me redescends le prix d'une
maison dans un sac à main j'espère que
tu me redescends on est ensemble et je
sais ce qu'il achète c'est ce qu'il
achète pas une voiture à 160 américain
exactement et tu me casses la mâchoire
et la nuit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]